despite Barbie being nominated for best
picture for the 2024 Academy Awards
Margot Robbie wasn't nominated for best
leading actress and Greta Gerwig was
shut out of Best Director category in
the end these snubs are dispiriting but
utterly unsurprising here's why year
after year the best picture race is
predominantly occupied by movies helmed
by men white men more often than not
with only a few women breaking through
to secure a nomination it's important to
note that in the Academy's 95 year
history only three women have ever won
the top prize Katherine Bigalow for The
Hurt Locker in 2009 Khloe Xiao for nomad
land in 2021 and Jane Campion for the
power of the dog in 2022 it's also
important to say that at the upcoming
96th Oscars French director Justine
Trier is the sole woman recognized in
the category and last year zero female
directors were nominated this is an
obvious and systemic issue Greta Gerwig
is actually a pretty fascinating example
of a woman who fre quently receives
half-hearted seemingly insincere honors
from the academy without actual tangible
recognition yes she was nominated for
directing ladybird but she lost a g mod
Del Toro for the shape of water and was
up against only men her sophomore effort
Little Women scored a best picture nod
and ignored gerwig's considerable work
from behind the camera now with Barbie
Gerwig has been shut out for her third
critically acclaimed film The snub is
egregious but it's also par for the
course at this
point everything's almost like reversed
here Margo Robbie is technically an
Oscar nominee at the 96th Academy Awards
but not for her performance in Barbie as
a producer she earned a nomination for
its inclusion in the best picture
category this is at face value pretty
shocking especially when you consider
that Robbie was perhaps edged out by
Carrie Mulligan in Bradley Cooper's
biopic Maestro which was met with mixed
reviews Robbie does something fairly
spectacular in Barbie considering that
she transforms a America's most famous
doll into a fully realized character
Robbie's vision of Barbie aided in no
small part by Greta gerwig's excellent
yet unrecognized Direction and The
Script she co-wrote with her partner
Noah bombach takes her on a journey that
transforms her into a real person
someone desperate to become the one who
imagines instead of being simply an idea
in doing all of this Robbie commits one
of the biggest sins possible in the eyes
of the motion picture Academy she's
funny I don't have anything big planned
just a giant blowout party with all the
barbes imp plant choreography and a
bespoke song you should stop by comedy
is so consistently overlooked at the
Oscars that when Marissa toay won for
her Pitch Perfect performance in my
cousin Vinnie in 1992 rumors swirled for
years that presenter Jack Palance read
the wrong name Robbie's portrayal is
heartfelt emotional and compelling but
she also goes for broad comedy showing
off the full range of her acting ability
by combining Pratt Falls with tearful
admissions I'm not used to that having
anything in
it the Oscars rarely if ever reward
comedy likely because it's not viewed as
serious art compared to biopics or
movies that make people feel completely
depressed Robbie's performance being
ignored is yet another example of that
irritating Trend those excusing Barbie's
egregious omissions in best director and
leading actress might point to the fact
that the movie Broke multiple box office
records and made Greta Gerwig the first
female director to single-handedly helm
a movie that crossed the billion doll
mark all of these accomplishments may
have heard its full Oscar potential in
the end though Blockbusters like
comedies were staunchly ignored by the
academy for most of its history until
outcry over Christopher Nolan's
universally adored Batman take the Dark
Knight won a postumus acting award for
Heath Ledger without managing a best
picture nomination from 2010 on the best
picture category expanded to 10
potential winners usually tossing a
blockbuster into the frey to appease
fans and draw a bigger audience for The
Telecast movies like black panther top
gun Maverick and Mad Max Fury Road just
to name a few were never going to win
best picture but were nominated to keep
complaints to a minimum Barbie's billion
dooll box office Hall has relegated it
to the Token Blockbuster role this year
this is made particularly obvious
considering that it's nominated
alongside several smaller films
Oppenheimer was also a high grossing
cinematic Juggernaut in 2023 but unlike
Barbie Oppenheimer is more likely to be
regarded as serious because it's a
historical biopic about the creation of
the atomic bomb while Barbie apparently
loses artistic merit with each dollar it
makes Barbie ended up with best picture
and best adapted screenplay nominations
but it also scored two acting nods in
the supporting categories America
Ferrera who plays Mattel employee Gloria
and delivers the film's most memorable
monologue earned her first ever Oscar
nomination for supporting actress
unsurprisingly Ryan Gosling ended up
with a nomination for supporting actor
which is a problem Gosling's
performances to be fair truly excellent
he shines in every single second of the
film committing to his role as the
hapless horse obsessed Ken with the
utmost passion horses are just men
extenders his dream ballet set to the
Oscar nominated original song I'm just
Ken is certainly one of the movie's
standout moments that said it's a bit on
the nose to nominate Gosling and not
Margo Robbie considering that one of the
film's main conflicts is that Ken
overthrows the matriarchy of Barbie land
to install a patriarchy and become the
society's main character of sorts
nominating the only standout male
character from a movie about the female
experience and not the film's lead is
frankly insulting as are the other major
Barbie nominations unless it pulls a
full Argo its chances of winning best
picture are utterly insignificant
without Greta Gerwig in the best
director category it screenplay nod
feels like the academy giving a small
consolation prize to a movie that feels
too weird or unworthy to win the big
prize ultimately Barbie being overlooked
in majorly important categories isn't
all that shocking
but it does continue a disturbing
unsettling trend of not taking movies
seriously if they're too funny feminine
or
fantastical